looked defiant and confident but while
there was a strong union presence
outside the high court inside it was
nobody to argue the nurse's case
the High Court ruled the planned 48-hour
strike which starts on Sunday evening
could not extend into next Tuesday
because the RCN mandate will have
expired the judge Mr Justice Linden said
the union had shown a high degree of
unreasonableness that the outcome was
inevitable and instead of grasping their
nettle and conceding it had forced the
case to cause
the strike was called after nurses
rejected the government's payoffer
earlier this month this is the dorkest
day in this dispute so far
any government that would drag their
nursing staff through the courts they've
won their legal battle today but what
this has led to is they've lost nursing
and they've lost the public
the walkout will be the first to include
emergency departments cancer Awards and
Intensive Care staff like Bert it has
made me more determined I think
a government that rather goes to court
with for the nurses instead of sitting
in a negotiation room called me out and
we this is serious this is just a group
of people that doesn't know how to
respectfully sit together and and search
for a solution but bad and his
colleagues could still have the
government's offer imposed on them as
other unions continue to ballot members
ahead of talks next week the government
said it regretted taking this court
action but felt it was necessary to
protect patients the NHS estimates
nearly half a million appointments have
been delayed over the past five months
of industrial action by health workers
every day of strike has an impact on
patients it's outpatients appointments
canceled tests canceled operations
canceled and absolutely you know we
don't want to stop at the right to
strike but it has to be done in a legal
way the RCN says it will read ballot
members over future strike action if
further dates are announced the union
now knows to make sure they're not
breaking the law oh she's joshing Sky
News at London's High Court